[Música]
o local do jogo devido a mais um vídeo e
hoje eu vou ensinar como fazer uma mini
campo totalizando uma caixa de cartão e
agora vamos começar vou começar a fazer
as letras na ponta e para isso
utilizaram um esquadro uma régua de 20
centímetros de uma caneta em pedaços do
cartão que tirei do meu caixa falha por
traçar uma linha de 20 centímetros
seguindo a orientação do cartão como
vocês podem ver as linhas tão desta
forma ea linha está tem paralelo com
essas cruzava os quadros em maio de 2005
em tempos na extremidade para cima a
mesma coisa aqui na clínica vai desta
partida até esta parte aqui e fazendo
desta forma contratado vou aproveitar
carrega está aqui e marcar com o centro
de 1350
já na esquadra
vou tratar o incidente para cima
a mesma coisa estação da marca
agora fechar aqui em cima
assim é útil e vou traçar uma linha de
escanteio que até este cantinho que
deste lado
agora vamos ter daqui para dentro do
centro
daqui pra baixo dois sentidos pelos
também e agora vou juntar em dois pontos
porém curtar vou usar esta estava por
baixo e assim evite estragar é mesmo e
utilizar utilizado então se vocês forem
crianças peçam ajuda do que está vamos
precisar de dez pacientes como esta aqui
então vamos usar isso como mall ou seja
vamos usar isso com preferência foi
criar as outras e se não temos cozinhar
tudo de novo
é só colocar isso em cima do cartão
sobrar bancos de luxo e contornar a
volta porque nós simplesmente sempre
esta peça para criar os anos porque
desta forma todos os pecinhas que vocês
fizerem vão ficar iguais destas aqui vai
ficar ligeiramente maior do que esta
então vocês passam todas elas o exame e
se molda e guarda nem para fazer depois
outras épocas mais para frente
[Música]
e agora vou ensinar como fazer a colher
primário você tem que desenhar um
retângulo que tem 14 centímetros por 2,5
aqui em cima e temos aqui um catálogo
com 14 por 2,5 e agora vou marcar várias
medidas então fiquem atentos para baixo
10,5 e 11 e 13,5 e deste lado
basicamente temos um triângulo de um
lado e do outro lado são iguais
junto é este aqui com esta linha é a
mesma coisa de lado e agora só tenho que
fazer uma linha que junta esta parte que
esta parte aqui deste lado
caí no total vamos precisar de duas
peças como está aqui porém tem sua
espécie em risco fica no interior da
colher então a única representa esta
peça e outras três por aqui dentro que é
que nós vamos colocar com os objetos que
vão ser lançados pela que aponta
já não é cantora jô
sim
[Música]
já traí
a decisão do sul
eu estava
[Música]
longe
procurei ficar tempo mais vamos precisar
de colocar um espaçador um lado e outro
do outro lado é para medir isso basta
empurrar a colher para um dos lados pois
corrégo medir a distância
temos aqui 5,3 então eu vou cortar um
pedaço de caneta com 2,5 centímetros de
sódio e 2,5 centímetros para este lado
aqui ok agora vamos terminar o projeto
primeiro vou colocar o eixo que é da
mesma maneira que até voltar no futuro
colocar um professor de 2005 que eu
tenho é que fazer pra colher agora um
outro espaço
- com certeza por este fundo desse lado
já está feito ea nossa colher desta
forma fica centralizada para não ter
laço e vamos precisar de dois pontos
desde que tenha porta da frente que está
afiada isso ajuda a passar pelo meio do
cartão
aí eu vou vir aqui apontar contrário
gostar este coletivo em cima
pelo meio das chamadas vejam que seria
faltar vou colocar um elástico em furar
o pleito até passar para este lado da
frente
desta forma o plástico vai ficar preso a
encontrar o que colher
estamos fazendo a mesma coisa um pouco
mais difícil porque lá está esticado
tentar porém está na mesma altura o
pleito do outro lado para tentar obter
um certo mas acho que é assim
já foi terrível agora vai ser só a força
desta que o deputado
[Música]
e pronto aos campos o fim eu espero que
vocês tenham gostado deste projeto aqui
é na hora de brincar com isto dizer
óculos de proteção e sejam responsáveis
e isso tem alguma sugestão de algum
projeto é só deixar nos comentários
é isso muito obrigado até a próxima
etapa